thank you
[Music]
all right picture this
using the most illustrative imagination
you can one french guy
on a kayak he has a beret a striped
shirt I pictured a mime on a kayak a
mime on a kayak you're so [ __ ] keep
going Jesus Christ
yeah with a baguette I like the most
racist versions of imagination I'm just
picturing Ryan's words so those are
racist
a french guy on a kayak yeah sorry
already derogatory I just started one
French man on a kayak
croissant across the ocean oh he just
had a drink of espresso he's all alone
and he makes it
from California
all the way to Hawaii
first of all 32 days that's not that's
true but not true why is a french guy in
California like why did why does he like
not speak English that's what you're
that's the thing that got your attention
that he's in California like why did
they describe him as a french guy in
California my mime because he's a
Parisian got [ __ ] sunburned like a
[ __ ] dude 90 days in the sun
dude how do you feel
2400 miles of this right here
2400 I saw a guy with a little sailboat
that did that on YouTube yeah there's
been a guy that did it with uh a sale
driven almost like a canoe thing with a
sale on it he did it in like 60
something days but this is the first guy
to do it with nothing but personal power
yeah cause kayak oh yeah if it's like
that or he's got the bike kayak this one
he did this for 90 days 2400 miles and
he slept like that too
I hope it was like a race thing or like
it was organized and he had somebody
with him like a safety vehicle yeah
because if he's there by himself that's
badass man yeah he's all alone all he
had was like communication with people
you know in case something happens and
he could get a helicopter to come save
him yeah he did try one time and he had
to stop in a helicopter like did I think
that's a lot of money uh but he didn't
they dropped him off the what the
helicopter came and they're like okay
like a claw game and just
that's cool though I like when people
like challenge human abilities and by
the way he's not some like super mega
athlete guy that like you know he this
is just a regular dude that just wanted
to do it so does that mean kayaking is
like not that crazy then that was his
goal so that everyone goes kayaking must
not be that he just he just made
kayaking look so much weaker because
he's on like trust me I'm like I'm not
even an athlete dude's [ __ ] easy bro
it's not a triathlete did he have GPS or
did he use the constellation so that's a
good question so the crazy thing is he
did have um yeah he had some equipment
on there
um I believe he did have a GPS but the
crazy thing is the guy that he was
inspired by who who did it I think like
um in in 1987. his kayak had like a
little kite on it that guy didn't have
no GPS he just had to Nowhere this is
the old school way he had MapQuest
printed out
because back then you just had to do
that you just had to print it out and
then make a right make a roll back yeah
did he have like canned food and like
crackers and [ __ ] or did he like fish
for us oh my God if you start from zero
that's crazy no he had supplies and he
had communication and yeah still insane
yeah with supplies on the boat but one
thing that's crazy badass one thing
that's crazy is that so like within
those you know three something months he
didn't get to fully stand up
so his legs were like like he was
[ __ ] pissing and sleeping sitting
down does he have back problems I think
he's good he's okay but then he that's
one thing that he was saying is like now
that I'm on like Hawaii he's like oh I
can't wait for vacation because like to
not be standing fully for three months
his upper body must have been Jack yeah
his legs just limp he just comes out
like a Johnny Bravo [ __ ] French knew
this [ __ ] I would have got out the [ __ ]
in the water or something maybe he had
some kind of like ass catheter or
something or like a hole in the windows
swim
I guess you could stretch your legs get
some yeah maybe if there was a hole like
right around his [ __ ] but he never
stood up
like his own like plug because I've seen
a tutorial I've seen a tutorial on how
to plug up a boat that's sinking if it's
a small hole yeah this guy got a got
hard and he stuck his penis in there and
then he started drinking he was drinking
the water that was that was flooding the
boat and then he peed it out Is that
real what it was a cartoon tutorial okay
but if that guy did that when he gets to
Hawaii they'd just be like a shriveled
circle around his ass
haha it's kind of like your fingers
it's so pretty I don't know are there
any other ways we can uh demean this
man's achievement
poor guy I think it's badass man that's
cool three months holy [ __ ] yeah why
didn't he just do it in the
Mediterranean see why do you have to go
to California to Hawaii I guess he
really liked the idea of going from like
actual California I wonder which island
he got to First yeah Hilo oh so big
because that's the first one huh yeah
you're not gonna go to the end she goes
around it he's by the shore but still
tired
they could just see him they're like who
is that guy what is he doing I want to
see some of these waves that they see in
the ocean uh open ocean because
sometimes like you'll see you know
footage of of these big tankers and and
there's these massive waves that they're
climbing but then like you can't really
tell the scale of it because it's just a
little screen right they're like four or
five stories yeah it's huge that big
wave in Portugal I forget what it's
called like they're really famous the
one that they serve yeah my friends
Brothers the surfer she's from Portugal
and he serves to every year it's yeah
when you look at it you can't even
process how big that is right and then
you see the the surfer on it the little
dot yeah they look like a little dot
with a little like like an airplane just
doing Chemtrails and [ __ ] you know and
then and then you're like wait how big
is that really I want to see one so
crazy in real life huh yeah I want to
see one this dude was saying um one of
the coolest things was that when you're
out there for that long alone like you
really start to like see other people
with you you know like it's like what
mine just starts to like pass away
so like he was saying that like oh so
his inspiration the guy who did it
before him in the 80s he was imagining
that he was doing it together with that
guy
and then afterwards that guy's still
alive and he told the guy like hey I
felt like I could see you like with me
was he like get out of here you creep
he's like no I saw you too you're just
in my room for some reason
astral projection the cool thing is when
he told him that the guy knew exactly
how he felt because he's probably one of
the only people that can understand that
yeah and he was like that's exactly what
happened can you imagine hallucinating
so hard on not even drugs but just by
being alone solitary confinement that
yeah and I wonder at what day that
happens because it's like is it the 30th
day yeah like and then before you know
it you're like
hey dude come on Michael Jackson come on
man or they they have like these
isolation tanks you can actually pay to
go in like this isolated chamber where
you're like in water floating oh yeah
yeah and it's like completely dark sound
pretty like nothing yeah and then people
start hallucinating like 30 minutes in I
I only sold it I did I just got some of
the water in my eye and then burning
like crazy and I was like how the [ __ ]
do you get rid of this [ __ ] man yeah
cause it's the the extra salt to keep
that was floating though it was nice
yeah it is nice
but you didn't feel no I feel like you
got to be in there for a good amount of
time how long were you in there it's
usually like an hour or something I
don't hallucinate enough
have you seen that movie
I forget what it's called it's about
like that guy stuck on an island and a
dead body washes oh I know what you're
talking about the man one movie is
called the body washes up I'm sure no
Swiss army man Swiss army man Daniel
Radcliffe that movie is so funny oh it's
dope you gotta watch it hilarious it's
crazy the guys who made everything
everywhere stuck on an island he's about
to like commit suicide and he's like
really upset in this dead body washes up
on shore and he brings it with him and
like starts like it's his friend like
talking to it uses his arm to like cut a
tree you gotta watch is this funny movie
yeah it's like funny but kind of deep oh
okay it's really interesting it's the
guys who made everything everywhere same
directors I like it it's Harry Potter
and The Riddler so okay now I've heard
of it yeah what's that one with the
[ __ ] Mr Richard Peters the love the
little Indian boy that gets trapped in
the life of pie it's really good that's
good because of the introspective thing
of like was it really the animal see he
was he was hallucinating man yeah yeah
that one's really good but this dude uh
yeah he did great he made it one of the
cool things about his trip is that
because he did in a kayak they're having
people that did it before like we were
saying with the little boat out of the
sale another woman did it with a rowboat
he did it on a kayak which means he did
it the closest to the surface of the
water with his body so he's more prone
to like if something happened a big wave
like he's going out like you lose your
food yeah because he has to be like low
enough to hit these rows right so what
he did is that much more remarkable
because of that the risk is way greater
I want to do it in a glass submarine
what oh jet ski there oh but you're
gonna run out of fuel
yeah if you can do it on a kayak I don't
know just take a big ass I feel like
you'd run out of gas first yeah
foreign